new at 11 it was report card night so to
speak for clark county superintendent
superintendent dr jesus jarrah
the school board provided its official
rating of his work over the past year
doing really a deep dive into several
action points
overall board members say there is room
for improvement
but they're ready to do it together the
superintendent
you're you're still our leader we need
you let's work together
and get take care of these kids and all
of our staff and our community
i want you to know that i am confident
that
you and this new board will work
together with dr aldry
you guys will um rewrite some of the
policies
to be grouped a little bit better
together and
that in six months to a year
that things will be in a much better
place
now superintendent jar responded saying
in part
i will continue to communicate
transparently
and directly on all matters affecting
our students and schools
this will be even more critical as
safely reopening our school soon becomes
a reality you can read the full
statement on our website at 8newsnow.com